welcome to this video was L ml11 sir
gentleman number or something okay um
BOGO again maybe I should check them
something else more often what I'd like
to test the repertoire from a book but
I'd like to explore some new things
maybe in the near future ok this line is
interesting Black is now intending 94 so
mostly they go Knight c3 after which
black can play d 5 with an interesting
position I had that in earlier games the
most interesting continuation i think is
Bishop g2 now and after which I will
take an owl 95 years so i have to take
97
that's not primo here I mean 95 would be
very very much speculative removed but
okay why is he taking time now maybe had
to get the coffee or something so what
is this very early queen deform mmm
Galaga I mean I played this before I
just wonder some gives Quincy five a
move yet always this stupid takes takes
Knight b5 this this could be could be a
annoying hmm now it's probably not a
good idea okay i can go Knight b6 spit
I don't know is this such a bad idea I'm
kind of intrigued by that takes takes 9
p-5 king is seven and of course it's not
even thinking about it it's the only
really critical move quite clearly i
think but ok so why am i not just a pawn
up here is going for look you won or
something hoopty one and 54 so ok so
getting ready for b5 and just claim to
have an extra point I mean so antiques
and b5 ok so fatigued p38 eggs I'm not
going to keep my pawn but I can do plexi
5c 5 takes and before do I need to play
c-54 that or can I just go king is seven
it's an interesting question c5 is
weakening quite a bit so I'm doing here
takes NV form
not he has the possibility to go see
five now but this is also giving my
bishop some additional scope so just a
five yeah I think I should be quite
comfortable here it's double porn is not
really really doing that much okay maybe
he can get the rope to c5 def definitely
am so maybe here get this over there and
now things takes by bishop doesn't have
many squares it's a slight issue here
but okay if he takes on b5 we should be
five will attack the porn okay so it's
doing this now I can take my bishop
doesn't have squares this is really kind
of problematic so here right you cannot
trap it or anything at least I don't see
how a three does be too and I'm
promoting no I'm not promoting
can you go away three here be too ok
it's not trying yeah I can just push
this thing push this point home in some
way like take a for a for a five and
then bring the King around yes a 3-1 or
no I can I think I can start with that
with this and let's do here let's see
where to go rook a for King these
freaking bad Kings III I'm going around
and winning the sea porn yeah that
should be enough time working
winning the sea porn for winning king
and porn end game should get into zoosk
one maybe you can try to play the rook
endgame somehow like waiting for me to
take on c6 with the king no he just goes
into the lost endgame just like that at
least that would be remarkable of it
wouldn't be lost maybe he can block
things I mean it's not entirely
impossible but I don't really think so
he should get he should run out of moves
pretty soonish after c5 I can always go
King be 66 and let him run out of moves
his double porn is worthless him check
yeah I'm just shuffling now
is there any special thing that I have
to have to watch out for don't think so
really you for I can do this you four
kings is six most they have to watch for
the time I'm not an Aquino a killer can
push forward yeah no I'm just pushing
here I'm not taking anything not sure I
mean maybe I could have taken but the
point is promoted promoting so no need
to do anything else surprise that you
just went to the king at porn and game
which would resign this is very clearly
lost and may i came i think the position
is winning anyway but i think you could
have could have tried could have tried
to get her to be a bit more resilient i
know some let's say this and I go here
you three and if i take then shall check
and then block with the king but ok well
i have the sea pony with it it wins it
wins as well but after that just it's
just very clearly lost it's funny that
stock fish even takes a while to
actually i said just just with every
imply it gets gets deeper and that gets
lower at NOAA like minus 2 minus 3 and
so on yeah so i think the critical idea
was very early actually has to play 95
which I felt was was completely
completely forced I mean you have to go
now be five year otherwise that that
whole thing doesn't make any sense so
what why didn't you do that maybe it may
be something on the D file that's the
only thing that like this if I go Bishop
g7 look T for
this is also the atom put short castles
this is just an not doing anything but
it's a Cleveland yeah no I'm ready for
b5 I mean here only black can be better
I mean maybe he can equalize the
computer says white can equalize with 94
ticks ticks b5 and now a for a 406 a be
Bishop b5 would just slide edge for
black yeah but really I'm upon up so I'm
not I mean you can totally al you about
how big blacks advantages are just a
pawn yeah here can can get serious very
very quickly this I was really not doing
much to prevent what what happened
really and now white white can certainly
be tougher in its defense I wasn't
entirely sure actually if this is using
immediately be too how do I get okay i
can just do this actually okay okay okay
or hope da da loop d8 is actually strong
taking them okay cumin down there that
felt okay i think i played it all right
don't really see much room for
improvement at the moment okay well
thanks for watching